There’s something profound
about the innocence of a child.
And to the untrained eye, SCP-053 seems like
an adorable little three-year-old girl - the
epitome of innocence. However, just being
too close to her can be incredibly dangerous,
as being in her presence for longer
than ten minutes will provoke paranoia
and homicidal urges in
anyone over the age of three.
Eventually, those affected will begin to act
on these urges, killing everyone around them
and then attacking the little girl. However,
attempts to physically harm her will cause
the attacker to die immediately. SCP-053 will
regenerate instantaneously from any physical
damage done to her regardless of severity, and
will appear wholly ignorant to the experience.
Surprisingly, when introduced to SCP-682, she had
the complete opposite effect on her new playmate.
Her being around 682 made
the beast shockingly docile,
causing it to calm down and allowing
her to play with it. But of course,
it immediately started killing people
again as soon as she left. How rude.